Now that's really cool which means for any coin flip in any sample size,
you can compute for me how confident you are.
If in the coin flip, you came back to saying, wow I believe it's the 0.44,
you can now say, well, given the number of same as the head, it's not 0.44. It's a confidence interval.
It's a certain way of maybe ±0.07 that gets added to the 0.44
that they can be confident about according to our method study so far.
In practice, in which you were given a sample and you don't know the exact value of p.
Suppose this is the sample you observed, N=4 and we're going to apply the formula
even though we understand it should only apply when N is equal or larger than 30.
Just for the exercise of applying the formula, compute for me the mean and the variance.
The variance, I don't need the formula variance but the variance,
I mean the actual variance from the data sequence.